welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and in the tall
grass tops off a phenomenal year for
Stephen King with the new horror making
people across the world everywhere
afraid to mow their lawns if the ending
of in the tall grass left you as lost as
the characters in the film then don't
worry because we have the answers here
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the movie and its ending there
will of course be heavy spoilers here so
if you haven't had a chance to watch the
film yet and don't want anything
potentially ruin it then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of in the tall
grass the film opens with a very Jeepers
Creepers esque premise as we follow a
brother and sister pair Cal and a
heavily pregnant Becky who stopped
during a sweltering car journey to
rescue a boy who seemingly appears to be
lost in a field they soon realize that
something is amiss and this field of
dreams quickly turns into a field of
screams as the two discover that the
grass is hiding a terrible secret in the
tall grass
instantly gripped me and watching the
pair wander round the unforgiving maze
that purposely twisted and changed in
order to manipulate them was harrowing
throughout it's a unique horror setting
and wilds concepts like this where
nature is the enemy have been discussed
in films like The Happening in the tall
grass certainly feels a lot less
laughable and far more terrifying anyone
who has ever been lost in a strange
place will be able to relate to this
early on and whilst the film doesn't
completely hit the mark every time it
definitely kept my interest throughout
after being trapped in the grass for the
best part of a day Cal stumbles across
Tobin The Lost Boy and Becky discovers
his father Ross played by Patrick Wilson
both seem pretty untrustworthy and weird
and Tobin leads Cal to the center of the
maze where he comes across a giant rock
that apparently allows those who touch
it to learn the secrets of the tall
grass now those who read the book may be
surprised by just how close to the
source material that this story sticks
with the initial opening being pretty
much the way things happen in the work
by Stephen King and Joe
though the film carries on after the
events of the story at some points I
think fans of the work will definitely
lap this up and find the changes
engaging this flesh is out the main
storyline far beyond what we have in the
book and feels like the next logical
step
anyway after some time passes Travis
machine
Becky's baby's father arrives at the
grass after searching for the pair he
too unwittingly enters it and similar to
Cal stumbles across Tobin who seems to
know him and says he knows Becky he
leads him to a dead body and disappears
and the next day Travis calls out to
Tobin's family who have just arrived in
the area now Tobin pays lip service to
the fact that he and Travis are
connected and the others in the grass
aunt which saw a flashes out how there
are multiple realities and timelines
existing in the grass similar to the
grass itself time in the area is able to
move and Bend with those from the future
pulling in people who exist in the grass
in the past the constantly altering
perspective of the film may be confusing
without the prior knowledge that time in
the grass moves completely differently
to how we as humans perceive it but it
does follow certain rules the grass is
able to alter the past whilst retaining
elements of the future and this is how
Travis is able to be pulled in then pull
Tobin in who pulls Becky in who
eventually pulls in Travis the future is
the past as the past is the present and
the grass itself is an entity that uses
its prey to lure in more prey who in
turn lower and more prey constantly
changing the pathway of time similar to
how it changes the pathways of those
trapped within it the grass even alters
the past as we see when Travis cow Becky
and Tobin all meet one another even
though we know this didn't originally
happen so from this we can decipher that
the grass is able to create a timeline
take elements of that timeline move them
across to an alternate one that wipes
the original timeline and then use this
to gain more prey this is confirmed by
the fact that later in the film
Ross is able to kill Cal as he has done
it several times before because you can
predict that the way that the character
will move in certain circumstances now
if you don't have a PhD in theoretical
physics that you still might find this
confusing but basically the grass can do
what it wants this is all controlled by
a giant rock that is perceived by Ross
to be the center of
the world if not the universe the rock
witches millennia-old requires a touch
in order to gain its knowledge and Cal
almost reaches out and grabs it when
Tobin's mother Natalie from an alternate
timeline is pulled into the circle to
stop everything this leads to Ross
killing Natalie and beating Travis after
he refuses to touch the rock and in my
opinion the movie is a metaphor for how
those who believe that they have the
answers are sometimes willing to use
violence in order to try and force
others to see it we as a species are all
wandering through our own grass lost
with no real idea of what's going on
whilst others trying forces to see
things their way
none of us can really see the woods for
the trees yet something they know better
and similar to the group in this we have
to be careful about who we decide to
follow this is exemplified by Becky who
could have followed Travis in order to
have a family or her brother who didn't
believe that Travis was good enough for
her both had their prejudices and
failings and thus Betty's child would
have its advantages and disadvantages
but ultimately Cal is shown to be a bad
selfish person that is as forceful as
Ross due to the fact that he allows
Travis to seemingly fall to his death to
me this personifies how the left and
right both have their dark sides and
whilst Netflix shows are often accused
of being skewed towards a liberal agenda
I think this paints out a pretty fair
portrait of how society works with all
aspects having its pros and cons after
running from Ross the group find a
rundown bowling alley in the grass that
they take refuge in and Cal seemingly
kills Travis and Ross kills cow and we
are pretty much given the message that
had everyone decided to work together
instead of in their two divisions that
they probably could have escaped the
grass if they had have made the choice
to escape they could have but they
constantly made the wrong one and
therefore the grass is able to hold them
in its web Tobin is the main signifier
of this as we see certain versions where
he takes on a twisted and dog persona
and other versions where he's a brighter
happier being to me this solidifies that
children are a feature and if we lead
them in a similar way that Becky does
where she allows Tobin to have choices
instead of through force there will be a
more positive outcome Travis too
realizes that he made the wrong choice
in abandoning Becky and she realizes
that she did too by wishing to give her
baby up for adoption
the
is a representation of going through
hardship and coming out better for her
on the other side by making the correct
choice whilst this version of Becky
Travis and Ross welcome to end up on the
tragic path that was teased throughout
the film there is hope as Becky is able
to contact the outside world with a
warning and Travis touches the rock and
is able to see all of the pathways and
lead Tobin out
Tobin reaches the church on the outside
of the field and is able to warn Becky
and Cal at the start of the film before
they make the wrong choice because of
this the characters are able to avoid
the area and they will go on to lead the
lives that they should have had to me
this signifies that we are all in
control of our destinies and if we can
escape the trappings of the wrong choice
early on either by ourselves or with
help from others then we will be able to
go in the right direction the film
closes with Becky realizing that her
future lies with Travis and their baby
it solidifies that we can help ourselves
even when things look bleak a stand is a
rather more hopeful ending than is
simply presented we watch as the good
Travis collapses in the field safe in
the knowledge that out there there is a
version of himself that is leading the
life he should have had which is when we
cut two credits and now on to my review
in the tall grass is a really enjoyable
horror film that once a thinks suffers
from some pacing issues and a muddled
final act still has a lot going for it
though this won't be for everyone as far
as Tara goes this is a unique movie that
will keep you engaged throughout due to
its mind-bending premise in the tall
grass is relatable enough so that you
would question what you would do in such
circumstances and like the best horrors
it perfectly allows you to feel the fear
that the characters are going through
it's a brilliantly self-contained story
that is another fantastic adaptation of
King's work and if you weren't certain
that we were in its third career revival
then this should definitely hammer at
home I would love to see more standalone
horror films on Netflix like this that
take an awesome premise and twist your
expectations in several surprising ways
in the tall grass is grey and that's why
it gets a 7 out of 10 now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on in the
tall grass
and if you agree or disagree with me
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
this weekend's are the big release Joker
which should be linked at the end I'll
give my thoughts on the film as well as
its true mean
so make sure you check that out after
this if you want something else to watch
you want to come chat to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books that make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this also just wanna let you
know that we're currently giving away a
free copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
in the tall grass in the comments
section below the winner will be chosen
at random on October the 15th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]